[Musica]
quanto spazio c'è in un litro è un dm
cubo 10 x 10 x 10 centimetri e che cosa
possiamo fare in uno spazio così piccolo
possiamo fare un piccolo recipiente una
bottiglia da un litro oppure possiamo
fare un piccolo laboratorio spaziale
umano satellite nano se confrontato con
i satelliti da tonnellate che tutti
siamo abituati a conoscere
ora le missioni spaziali sono il massimo
della complessità tecnologica della
complessità organizzativa ci sono team
di migliaia di persone in tutto il mondo
che lavorano una singola missione che
devono
coordinarsi sincronizzare le loro
attività per arrivare ad avere un
satellite in orbita e la complessità di
una missione spaziale è proprio il suo
stesso limite ora c'è un professore a
stanford il professor tweaks che vuole
rompere questo muro di complessità
io mi trovavo a stanford in quel periodo
con una borsa di studio visto come le
aziende della silicon valley le aziende
spaziali della silicon valley vedevano
che i giovani ingegneri spaziali di
stanford tra i migliori al mondo molto
capaci molto preparati però mancavano di
una visione dell'intero processo della
missione spaziale sì perché la missione
spaziale è un processo una complessa
sequenza di eventi che devono
verificarsi in maniera rigorosa per
poter avere un satellite nello spazio
e come si insegna a dei giovani
ingegneri spaziali a relazionarsi con la
complessità di una missione spaziale
come si insegna a gestire le risorse
come si insegna a gestire risorse non
soltanto economica ma anche il tempo
necessario per lo sviluppo della
missione il rischio il bilancio tra
rischio e risorse impiegate e non si può
insegnare coi metodi tradizionali dalla
con equazioni diagrammi o testi serve
una scuola guida per ingegneri spaziali
questo è quello che deve fare tweaks a
stanford alla fine degli anni 90 fa
quello che gli viene richiesto la sua
sfida
per questo costruire una scuola guida
per ingegneri spaziali serve quello che
viene chiamato in forma learning cioè
insegnamento non formale
trasmettere la conoscenza in maniera non
codificata ma semplicemente
trasmettendola lavorando insieme
il primo scoglio che tweaks deve
affrontare è il lancio del satellite il
lancio è la fase in assoluto più
delicata della missione spaziale quando
il satellite da terra si stacca e deve
raggiungere la velocità orbitale la
velocità orbitale è elevatissima per per
farci un'idea parliamo di 77 chilometri
e mezzo al secondo ora noi qui siamo a
pavia pensate di trovarvi alla certosa
di pavia
7 km appunto e coprire questa distanza
in un secondo
questa è la velocità che occorre per
andare in orbita e questo è il motivo
per cui occorre un sistema complicato
come un lanciatore un sistema di lancio
per immettere i satelliti in orbita
devono guadagnare questa velocità quindi
si tratta di un sistema molto costoso di
operazioni estremamente complicate
decine di milioni di dollari e
immaginate voi responsabile di una
missione spaziale di questo tipo che si
vede arrivare il giovane ingegnere
spaziale che deve fare la sua scuola
guida vuole mettere il suo satelliti no
per vedere come funziona in orbita è
chiaro che i rischi non sono accettabili
e quindi mix deve per prima cosa
convincere che i suoi studenti possono
viaggiare insieme ai fratelli
professionali e cosa suggerisce
costruiamo una scatola il satellite lo
imbarchiamo chiuso in una scatola così
qualsiasi cosa accada non ci possono
essere danni all'esterno la scatola è
certificata quindi garantita ci sono non
ci sono rischi poi una volta in orbita
la scatola si apre c'è una molla che
spinge il satellite su quattro binari e
il satellite fuoriesce un concetto
semplicissimo tecnicamente veramente
alla base al limite della della banalità
pro e io ho assistito però personalmente
a tante riunioni a tanti meeting
interminabili in cui gli esperti
spaziali dell'epoca si opponevano a
questo concetto dicevano che non avrebbe
mai funzionato che il satellite si
sarebbe incastrato che la molla non era
sufficiente che c'erano problemi termici
insomma volevano demolire assolutamente
questa idea non erano convinti proprio
perché non si era mai fatto così
ora questa idea è talmente fallimentare
che guardate cosa succede pochi anni
dopo che tweaks
suggerisce questo modello di nano
satellite
standardizzato tantissime università si
appassionano a questa idea diciamo oggi
diremmo che l'idea è diventata virale
addirittura le aziende si convincono che
in questo concetto cioè dell'innovazione
che può essere molto proficua e guardate
in questo grafico i satelliti riportati
in verde sono proprio satelliti
commerciali quindi tweaks vince la sua
scommessa questo articolo
questa foto è ripresa da un articolo che
si chiama ebid bet on smorzate light una
grande scommessa sui piccoli fratelli di
click sulla scommessa la vince
e questo ci fa riflettere sul fatto che
la complessità è senz'altro nella realtà
ma spesso è anche nel nostro modo di
interpretarla i cornet i buyers
pregiudizi cognitivi degli esperti che
volevano convincere tweaks a non
imbarcarsi in questa impresa
sono proprio parte di questa complessità
a volte mentale non solo appunto nella
realtà che limita lo sviluppo della
tecnologia ovviamente l'esperienza
rimane un valore fondamentale
tutta la nostra tecnica nostra
tecnologia si deve fondare su questo ma
bisogna avere anche l'occhio aperto
all'innovazione
l'altra chiave con cui tweaks st
scardina la complessità della missione
spaziale è lo standard
noi viviamo tutti i giorni circondati da
standard e neanche ci facciamo più caso
qui riportati alcuni ma ce ne potrebbero
essere tantissimi altri qual è l'idea
dello standard è che una volta che un
problema non è risolto e tecnicamente
consolidato si codifica un modo corretto
per farlo e quindi chi si approccia
quella disciplina si trova tutto un
lavoro già pronto e può dedicarsi ad
altro
ai problemi nuovi che la tecnologia
presenta ecco così che si rompe quel
mito del satellite come pezzo unico che
fino allora era stato predominante e si
passa un'economia di scala nei nano
satelliti
visto che il satellite standard se io
realizzo un un componente per un
satellite lo posso riutilizzare anche su
altri satelliti semplicemente perché la
forma e standard quindi c'è un
abbassamento un abbattimento dei costi
enorme e quindi da quella scuola guida
che tweaks voleva fare a stanford si è
passati alla economia di scala nei nelle
missioni piccole missioni spaziali ora
qual è quali sono i nuovi sviluppi che
possiamo pensare che possiamo prevedere
per una piattaforma di questo tipo beh
immaginiamo la missione più complicata
che ci viene in mente portare l'uomo su
marte ora la nasa pensa a una missione
concretamente se si pone questo problema
e è stata già definita la missione
artemis per riportare nuovamente l'uomo
sulla luna a colonizzare luna su base
permanente e utilizzare la luna per
andare verso marte ora prima di andare
avanti vorrei farvi riflettere su questa
immagine questa è l'immagine di come la
terra potrebbe apparire vista da marte
ora noi siamo abituati senz'altro a
vedere il mondo esterno quindi a vedere
i pianeti dal pon dal nostro punto di
vista vediamo i vari pianeti marte giove
saturno delle luci nel cielo però
vedersi noi stessi da un altro pianeta
questo cambia un po senz'altro la
prospettiva
e questo ci fa capire quanto è lungo un
viaggio per arrivare su marte occorrono
mesi e mesi di viaggio poi si dovrà
permanere per un certo periodo e poi
tornare quindi un viaggio di anni
immaginate voi lido per partire per una
il viaggio di tre quattro cinque anni e
dover riportare
il cibo e l'acqua le risorse che vi
servono per vivere e chiaro che è un
concetto che non funziona non è
verosimile quindi bisogna
pensare a dei sistemi che riciclino le
risorse esattamente come accade qui
sulla terra e gli attori fondamentali
del riciclo delle risorse sulla terra
sono proprio le piante qui vedete una
serra terrestre ma
prima o poi se dobbiamo pensare a delle
missioni spaziali di lungo periodo come
per andare su marte nel bagaglio
dell'astronauta dovrà esserci anche una
piccola serra di questo tipo che
fornisca cibo fresco e che sia in grado
di riciclare le risorse
ora come entra un piccolo laboratorio
spaziale come questo in un oceano di
complessità come la missione su marte
beh questa è una piccola goccia un
piccolo contributo che si può dare per
esempio proprio nello studio di come
crescono le piante nell'ambiente
spaziale l'ambiente spaziale un ambiente
completamente artificiale per la pianta
è lontano dalla dell'ambiente naturale
in cui la pianta si sviluppa e quindi
occorre studiare non solo come la pianta
si comporta in questo ambiente ma
soprattutto creare un ambiente che sia
favorevole per la pianta stessa e allora
con i colleghi dell'enea e
dell'università di napoli federico ii
con il coordinamento dell'agenzia
spaziale abbiamo pensato a questa
missione green cube dove
l'intenzione di far crescere delle micro
verdure all'interno di una nano serra
spaziale automatizzata come quella che
si può realizzare all'interno di un cook
set come questo
e qui vedete il video del primo
esperimento che è stato fatto a terra
ora il satellite non è ancora pronto per
andare in orbita quindi siamo a livello
di preparazione della missione ma vorrei
farvi vedere il livello di complessità
che c'è al supporto di questa nano serra
spaziale
occorrono ovviamente i nutrienti per la
pianta
occorre mantenere un ambiente favorevole
alla pianta soprattutto la temperatura
ma poi l'atmosfera siamo in vuoto
assoluto quindi bisogna mantenere
un'atmosfera adatta alla pianta la luce
la luce artificiale ovviamente la pianta
ha bisogno di luce quindi ci sarà una
luce artificiale che riproduce anche i
cicli giorno notte che abbiamo qui sulla
terra ma questo non basta ovviamente
servono anche dei sensori di un sistema
che possa monitorare lo stato della
pianta per gli scienziati che poi
analizzando i dati possano rendersi
appunto conto se l'esperimento sta
riuscendo se la pianta sta crescendo
come ci si aspetta
e qui vedete in questa immagine tutte e
due questi apparati gli apparati che
provvedono alla crescita della pianta e
gli apparati che invece provvedono al
monitoraggio
della della crescita della pianta di
accrescimento della pianta ora tutti i
satelliti sono
costituiti da due parti fondamentali una
parte esterna
che vada da protezione da involucro per
la parte interna il cuore del satellite
dove si svolge l'esperimento
è questa
questo rapporto complesso tra la parte
interna e la parte esterna di un
satellite è in qualche modo la metafora
del rapporto che lo stesso ingegnere lo
stesso tecnico che crea il satellite ha
con la realtà e con se stesso
l'opera dell'ingegneria e sempre pensata
soprattutto come un'opera razionale
senz'altro un opera nazionale un'opera
dell'intelletto
ma è anche un
processo emotivo un processo di
sentimenti molto complicati e profondi
che l'ingegnere prova quando vede
la sua opera
concepirsi e realizzarsi effettivamente
e questo momento è colto in maniera
magistrale secondo me in un sonetto in
dialetto romanesco scritto da carlo
arduini carlo arduini è stato il
fondatore della sistemistica spaziale
italiana è stato il primo professore di
sistemi spaziali alla sapienza e in
italia
e ha costruito è stato realizzatore del
satellite san marco il primo satellite
italiano
mi piace concludere proiettando il suo
sonetto per satellite insieme a questa
fotografia questa fotografia è stata
scattata da uno dei nostri cui 7 ha
lanciato e realizzato in collaborazione
con l'università di nairobi appunto in
kenya da dove il fratello di a san marco
del professore arduini è stato lanciato
i più attenti di voi vedranno sullo
sfondo una macchiolina grigia quello non
è un difetto dello schermo ma è la luna
che è comparsa in questa foto che è
stata coinvolta in questo foto lo
confesso occasionalmente non era
intenzionale
quindi vorrei concludere questo mio
tocco provando a leggere questo sonetto
bellissimo del professore arduini
scusandomi sin da ora per il risultato
però vorrei condividere con voi questo
questo momento questo sonetto che è
molto profondo si vede proprio arduini
il professore arduini l'ingegnere che si
specchia nella sua opera e attraverso
questo rispecchiarsi nella sua opera al
confrontarsi con la sua opera si
interroga sulla realtà ma soprattutto su
se stesso e sul rapporto
addirittura cosa al di là col divino e
non voglio dirvi oltre spero che questo
messaggio sia in grado di far velo
passare
per satellite
quella palla di ferro su per aria che
gira intorno a noi come la luna quella
l'ho messa io la super aria e cha doo
parte messe insieme in una una della suo
guarda sto mondo per mare il cielo è
questa terra bruna dove si vede sempre
stata una umanità gira intorno con la
sua fortuna
l'altra
guarda su in alto nel profondo sopra il
cielo della del velo spesso che circonda
il pianeta vagabondo e se square chasta
parte a cerca un nesso nelle cose che
girano qua in fondo dentro c'è un
pezzetto di me stesso
grazie